um is is
the whole committee here
eric is it
i do not see everybody okay we can wait
and see everybody actually
yes everybody's on sorry yeah okay salon
names
great and you're ready to go where
uh as much as i can yeah okay
great well welcome everyone to our uh
dmice informatics conference and um
as you know we have a lot of extra
conferences at the end of the
term people uh defending theses
dissertations proposals etc
so today uh we're going to have a
uh masters uh thesis defense
by um eric leung and um
many of us around the department know
eric he's been around
for a while and he is um finishing up
his
uh master's degree just just for those
of you um
who are not regulars at our conference
um
eric will um give his presentation
um and then um uh the
uh that then will be open to questions
from the public the public will be
excused leaving behind the committee and
eric they may have some further
questions for him then he'll be excused
and they'll make their decision
on whether he successfully defended his
thesis
so um just by way of bio
eric is a master of science student in
the bioinformatics and computational
biomedicine major
he got his undergraduate degree from the
university of oklahoma
where he received dual bachelor's
degrees in math and biochemistry
he leveraged his analytical and
biological backgrounds
to pivot into biomedical informatics and
study the human microbiome
he's also um often involved in community
efforts in open source software and
open science so he will defend his
master's thesis today
all years eric cool awesome thanks bill
i'll share my screen
[Music]
all right
move stuff around
oops i guess i move the slide all right
i'm assuming you can see the slide
let me know if i can't this is my title
so today i'll be talking about yeah the
research i've been doing
and to sum it up it is talking about the
urinary and vaginal microbiome community
structure
and women with urgency urinary
incontinence
and uh i think somebody's mic is on
somebody could mute that okay um yeah so
that title was a bit of a mouthful so
i'm going to take
a little bit the beginning to talk about
uh the three parts of that so
what is urgency urine incontinence and
why should we care about it
and then how the urinary and vaginal
microbiomes may play a role
in this condition and then transition
into
looking at the community structure using
these
co-current networks using more
network-based methods
i'll then go into my aims of my work
which are
split into more of the traditional way
in which we
analyze these methods and then exploring
more of these network-based ways
without further ado so i've spoken a lot
about urgency
and incontinence so what is it so
urgency urine incontinence or
eui is the involuntary leakage of urine
that is preceded by a strong sensation
to urinate
and so this strong sensation is this
urgency part
and so this is difficult to defer for
individuals with this
and so this condition does affect both
men and women
but by um surveys
and estimates it does affect more women
than men and additionally other
conditions that
are posed as risk factors for uui are
increased age and increased body mass
index
moreover this condition has a high
economic burden
both from a direct medical cost and from
indirect
costs from loss of productivity as as
you can imagine having to
have a sudden urge occasionally and ramp
now additionally this condition has
detrimental effects
on say a person's quality of life for
example an individual may have
embarrassment among their peer men
peer group having to leak or even having
to plan
out routes to the bathroom when they
might have
the urge to void
now there are treatments for urgency
urinary incontinence namely there are
these three broad categories
that are typically described which
increase in invasiveness as the previous
treatment becomes unsatisfactory to the
patient
now the least and most invasive
procedures are the behavioral techniques
such as time voids and then more
surgeries and
invasive techniques injections or
surgeries
now the largest class of treatments
which i'll focus on are these
medications
and typical medications are used are
anticholinergic drugs they're designed
to relax the muscle around the bladder
to prevent you from
having to go so much
now focusing on these medications they
do come with a range of side effects
such as dry mouth dizziness constipation
and blurred vision unfortunately to make
things worse
these uh medications are ineffective for
a very large population
of individuals with with your ui you
take this
so this suggests that there are
ideologies outside of
targeting the near muscular function of
the bladder to
treat this condition
and so stepping back a little bit from
the bladder one large piece of variation
that contributes to your genital health
and disease are microorganisms and so
your genitals
here will involve the reproductive
organs
including the vagina and the urinary
system including the bladder
and so there are a few bacterial
infections that affect
your general area such as bacterial
vaginosis and
sexually transmitted diseases and
urinary tract infections
and now considering the impact of these
microorganisms onto your genital health
we should consider the impact of these
impact of these microbes with
emergency urinary incontinence so going
back to the bladder so we have this
strong roll of these microbes by going
back to the bladder
uh we can you can see that medications
again will aim to relax
say the the bladder lining here
and with recent studies or not recent
studies rather
blather is not just a passive a barrier
made up of urothelia cells
rather it can react to stimuli
within the bladder and so much attention
has been concentrated
on the role of ural with urothelial
inflammation and infection in the urine
they may cause
sensitive bladder lining to
unnecessarily trigger
the bladder that can lead to emergency
urine incumbents
now historically we thought about the
bladder sterile however this paradigm
has been challenged in the past
decade and so for context here's a
standard urine culture after 24 hours on
a
blood blood auger plate and so there's
no growth here there's there's nothing
growing however with new expanded
quantitative um urine culturing
techniques
uh using this slightly more urine so
instead of one mil a microliter from
previous we're using a lot more and
growing it for longer
there is growth uh from from the urine
so one possibility here is that eui
symptoms are influenced by these
microbes that inhabit the bladder
and sure enough studies have found
changes in the microbiome
or the the bacteria in the bladder or
the urinary microbiome
that are associated with uui and here
i'm just showing this
subset of studies studying
uh various changes in the
urinary microbiome with respect to eui
so i brought up earlier that the
microbiome is important to your general
health
and the changes in the urinary
microbiome are now associated with
eui now the question is how does the
vaginal microbiome change with the
eui and so this is still an emerging
work
to understand this possible relationship
and how might we
look at these two together and also
the fact that the vaginal microbiome is
uh quite well studied and is a large
reservoir for bacteria
especially the large dominance of the
lactobacillus
bacteria as well
now i've talked about how these
microbiomes
and their changes and making
inferences about that and so what i mean
by how do we how do we quantify this
and so a very simple example here is
here i have two
two circles indicating maybe two samples
we're curious about
with the different species of these
boxes
that we're interested in so typical
questions we might want to ask
is the number and distribution of
bacteria
and we can quantify that as alpha
diversity and so this will look at
the um
sorry yes i mentioned the number and
distribution of these bacteria and so
you can
create replicates of these and versus
different groups
and compare them and similarly
you can also take each individual
sample and then compare the different
diversities across between each other
and create an ordination plot here so
you can more spatially understand these
and so what's missing from this is that
or rather these would be what i would
call more common or traditional methods
of how we would study these microbiomes
however these methods are
they make assumptions about just sitting
these bacteria
in isolation and one one tile actually
uh summarizes very aptly
uh that diversity is just a question and
not the answer
because we we see this diversity and
then you might say so what
then what what what populate or create
that certain
changes in diversity so we must look a
little bit deeper to understand what may
uh give this diversity
and so what's missing here is the
organisms will actually coexist
and have potential interactions with
each other so here on the right
i show a table of these interactions or
their ecological interactions rather
between pairs of organisms
and so there are pairs there are more
positive interactions such as
cooperations where both organisms
benefit
and then there's more negative
interactions where
both organisms may lose i say competing
for resources
and so this is just a pair of organisms
here or rather in bacteria in my case
however we can scale up this
table of interactions to a community to
abstract
say this invisible network of
interactions so here
is a such diagram where the
black circles here will represent each
of the bacterium
and these edges or lines between these
may be represent the different
interactions from this table
and so these misinteractions can be from
our analyses
can motivate these more network-based
methods they're emerging in their use
in the microbiome world
and so with that i'll get into my aims
so first
i'll characterize the microbiome of
women with
and without dui using these more
traditional methods
for both the urine urinary microbiome
and vaginal microbiome stipulated
and then i'll do a very similar analysis
but then
using more network based methods to then
characterize
each of the urinary microbiome and
vaginal microbiome
so i'm going to go in the next few
slides to talk about the study design we
did we had so first this was part of a
larger uh
cohort study that we had and in the
study here
i looked at 50 women 30 women without
urgency unincontinence and 20 women with
uui
there were a number of exclusion
criteria based on some
factors that may be confounding based on
our study
so some include needed intermittent
catheterization
or known neurological disease that may
affect bladder function
and individuals included in as uui
are predominant or urge predominant
incontinence confirmed on a three-day
bladder diary
so some of the information that was
collected was demographic information
to the page in bmi this three-day
bladder diary that i mentioned
which is a
a bladder diet that they take three days
they account for
what they've drank and their their
voiding patterns and how they felt
and then clinically validated surveys on
symptoms to
quantify their how they felt and
their severity of these symptoms
and of course we collected urinary and
vaginal
samples to then analyze that and
understand its relationship with your ui
so here's a brief summary table of what
we found between
our ui and control group for their
demographics so here notably their age
bmi
and history of their current urinary
tract infections were significantly
different
between our two groups another notable
demographics that didn't differ between
these are menopause status
estrogen used and race and ethnicity
a few of the questionnaires here these
are the symptom questionnaires
we asked our participants to take
and so here all of these here four of
them and all four of them were
significantly different between the two
and this is expected considering
uui patients have
this strong urge to go
and so take aways from just a study
population here is that we see
that uh individuals
with dui are much older and have higher
bmi
something that is a known risk factor
that we found
and then we found that uh individuals
with gui had significant
urinary tract symptoms also expected
and then menopause tests and estrogen
use were similar and that was based on
how the study was designed
okay so now in the next few slides i'll
take you through
how the samples were processed or
collected processed
uh and then prepared for final data
analysis to then
get into understanding microbiome
so previously in my background i
mentioned that bacteria in urine was
determined using culturing techniques
however there are now more high
throughput ways to understand these
by targeting the 16s gene that exists
only in
bacteria and so we can do
we can target that to then say the
microbiome
and so first we took catheterized urine
samples and vaginal swabs
both were taken by a trained clinical
uh professional and
we then extracted well targeted and
extracted the
bacterial dna and then amplified those
sequences
to be sequenced
after we get the sequencing reads back
then we process those sequences using
data2
we removed chimeric sequences and then
assigned our taxonomy using the silva
database
to the genus level and then we built a
phylogenetic tree
for downstream analyses
okay and then one more prep side
so here are three
large steps that we took to then prepare
this data
to be analyzed so first
do some pre-processing to remove out
some lowly abundant bacteria that maybe
may not expect or maybe from noise
then with such low biomass such as the
urine
we took some precautions and removed
contaminants using the deacon tam
algorithm and then we did some final
processing
to then keep expectation there from the
literature and then remove
known contaminants before
process before further going into
data analysis
okay so now we're at the data ready
uh section and then now here i'm going
to go over some of the traditional
analysis that i'll
show a subset of and so here are
a brief number of more of these
traditional analyses so first we can do
a unsupervised or clustering approach
to understand how generally the
compositions of these bacteria
associated with clinical information
and then we can get into these more
diversity measures that i briefly
alluded to at the beginning so looking
at the number and distribution
of bacteria between groups
and then how those diversity between the
samples may change between each other
and
we can more visually see how each of
those
samples are different and then
another piece we could do is what's
called differential abundance to look at
individual bacteria and how they may
differ
between groups
so firstly again we want to i'm going to
start with the
this unsupervised or this clustering
approach to see what
composition of the bacteria may relate
to
our clinical observations and cohort
status
so the data here we're clustered using
relative abundance
and so here i've shown a stack bar plot
of that
so here the x-axis is our samples the
y-axis
is our relative abundance each of our
genera
and each of them are colored by their
top genera here
so we performed hierarchical clustering
on our samples
using the weighted unifrac distance and
found
two groups based on the silhouette
metric to iden
uh to choose two groups here
and then these two groups by our
microbiome data do not appear
to associate with our cohort status or
having
uui or or not
and then exploring further these uh
clinical relationships
we see that there's no relationship
between vaginal product use
or estrogen use however there does
appear to be
an association in these groups of
menopause status
and relative abundance of lactobacillus
in the urinary microbiome here
now we can do a similar analysis to our
vaginal microbiome
so very similar setup here stack bar
plot
x axis is all different samples from
these same women
relative abundance the colors here match
the same
colors as before we perform
higher critical clustering
did the same clustering and using the
silhouette
distance to or metric to identify their
two groups i also found that there's no
grouping between these chord groups
or rather the ico clustering groups and
our cohort status
and looking at more of these clinical
pieces of information so we don't see
a significant association
with menopause status or estrogen use
between these two groups
however there does appear to be
significant
use of a rather significant difference
in use
of vaginal products and the relative
abundance of lactobacillus in these two
groups
now we've gone through a little bit of
the general
uh unclustered or rather clustering
between
samples and here we can look at now the
distribution and number of bacteria in
each of them so here i'm going to focus
on just the united microbiome and so one
quantity or one measure rather
of diversity alpha diversity is observed
number of taxa
and so uh here i have between
our ui grouping controls and then after
controlling for
ah bmi and menopause estrogen status
we see that there is no difference
between the different alpha diversity
of the urinary microbiome between eoi
and controls
and furthermore here are two other
common
uh measures of alpha diversity the
inverse simpson and the pilot
evenness also adjusting for the same
covariates
we see that there is no change in the
urinary microbiome
alpha diversity with eui
and similarly we can apply these same
measures to the vaginal microbiome
and consequently we don't see a
difference in the alpha diversity
of the vaginal microbiome in eui
controls as well
so this suggests that the number and
distribution of bacteria may not change
with having uui
another uh look at how these diversity
changes between samples
uh we can look at the what's called the
beta diversity here
and i find that they also don't vary
with uui either
and so on the left here i'm showing a
ordination plot
using our urinary microbiome samples and
after
performing a permanova test to test
whether it's samples
group by uui
we find that no relationship between how
the diversity changes between these
samples
and having uui
and similarly as you may guess i'll
do this same analysis on our vaginal
samples here
and we see a very similar result
that the vaginal microbiome
doesn't associate with dui and so
if it did you might see certain colors
here
may uh the colors here represent the
having uui and controls
and if they were associated with ui then
you would see all the
maybe salmon colored in one corner and
all the like more teal or blue
in a different color so you see here
they're all kind of spread apart
so as to take away from these more
traditional methods
so based on the urinary microbiome we
don't see any difference between
the different chords based on our
groupings however we did see
some effect of having
different menopause status and affecting
how the
urinary microbiome varies
and then for the vaginal microbiome we
also didn't see a change
in the associated with uui or
uh being control however we did see that
having
some vaginal product used actually does
influence the variation in the
vaginal microbiome to to cluster
samples in a certain way
and then in both we found that
lactobacillus is quite a dominant
feature
in influencing this variation
and then the last couple slides showed
that there we didn't find any
difference in the alpha diversity or the
distribution and number of bacteria
or the changes in those diversity
values
so at the beginning i mentioned these
possible limitations of these
traditional analyses not taking account
of these the context of the bacteria and
what they might be doing
and so here again is this table
of ecological interactions that i
brought previously
and so using these more network-based
methods we can
try to abstract these
interactions up to a community level and
generate this
a hypothesis if you will of the
interactions that may occur
in our community and so this might be
one
such way and so going forward so again
the circles here will be the different
bacteria
and the edges will be some sort of
relationship
that we may define and so because we
don't have the ground truth
we'll have to abstract or have a proxy
for that
as a certain edge and so what kind of
edge
or relationship will be defined here
and so the relationship that i'm going
to find here
is a correlation and so
to describe what that may look like
so here if i focus on just a bacteria a
and b
here and then we look at how
the abundances of them occur in
different samples so here
these different orange circles are the
different samples that we have
and as you can see as say
b abundance goes up in one sample
as it goes up then we can see that
a correspondingly also goes up and so
here we could
say that there's a strong correlation
between them
and may suggest some sort of interaction
that is occurring between them and so
this is
mapping it back to these ecological
interactions
and then another point i want to make is
what if there's no edge
between these two and so that could also
occur
whereby say we have this other bacteria
at c
where the abundance of this changes
across different samples
when say looking at a it doesn't change
at all
and so here it would be it would have a
very weak correlation or no correlation
at all so you wouldn't have an
edge there to connect them suggesting
any interaction
and then to keep uh
to keep the things a little bit simpler
here
i'm just going to be focusing on just
the positive correlations
for the network going forward
okay so that's a little bit of
background by all these networks
and so here's a very brief pipeline of
how to take
the microbiome data that we had
previously
and then transforming into a network and
so we take the abundance matrix
and we then calculate these correlations
and i use the sparse cc correlation
algorithm
which is designed for microbiome data
and then we performed a permutation
analysis to then generate
a null correlation distribution to then
threshold uh correlation set
to remove any more spurious or low lower
correlations
then performed more of these network
measures
and module detection algorithms to then
make use of this
now i guess our putative network
structure community structure and
identify properties of it that we
wouldn't have otherwise without the
network
and then we can visualize and then make
more informations about what this
network may mean
okay so on the next uh ending part here
i'm gonna spend time on talking about
the urinary microbiome
and then i'll switch gears and then talk
about the
vaginal microbiome networks that we have
so starting at the urinary microbiome so
here taking
the same samples we looked at previously
with the traditional methods i
constructed
a network for our eui
and then one for our controls and then
see
here i've colored them based on a
clustering item called infomat
sorry and then here infomative
identified
is it allows us to try to identify
some structure in this based on how the
network is constructed and so
with this algorithm we can identify
we've identified there are four groups
our ui network and then nine groups
in our controls
and a little bit more about these
networks from a
high network level so in our control
network we appear to have
a lot more bacteria so we have 135
bacteria
in our control network versus 93 in our
eui there's also subsequently
more edges or associations
of how bacteria can co-occur in our
control network
and then these modularity this
modularity measure
it quantifies how well the network will
group together
and so uh for a control group
we see that it has a higher modularity
measure which means that
it at least play this info map
algorithm it does group then a little
bit better
than say the for our ui group
this algorithm and then our normalized
conductance measure
quantifies the number of observed edges
that we've had or the co-occurrences we
have
out of all the possible co-occurrences
we could have
across all the bacteria in them and so
it appears that there are
more co-occurrences in our uui network
may which may suggest more variation in
how many
unique different bacteria may co-occur
in our ui network
than in our controls
so this is great at a very high like
network level which is
what we wanted to look at which is the
community structure and then now how
about we get into
some of the actual identities of these
bacteria and so here i've taken that
same network from before
but then annotated with a phylum level
and so here as as one of these network
analyses look like
they kind of look like a hairball
so i've taken some time to
redraw this to make it a little bit
easier to focus in on
the phylum level and seeing if there's
any
association differences between them
and so what i'm going to show you is
what's called a hive plot
and so on the top right here is the
representation of what looks before
i'm taking most of the data from here
and then just mapping it onto this what
looks to be a star diagram for now
and so i've taken all the different
phylum and aligned them
onto the different axes and so say this
vertical one right here this more salmon
color is all the actino bacteria
and our at least ui group and then
this purple would be all the
proteobacteria and so here we can
more easily align and push and focus on
each of the different phylum and then i
then take
all the edges and then i just draw them
between the corresponding bacteria as
they align
across this axis and so this may look
something like this and to make it
easier to visualize
i've only focused on a little a bit more
stronger correlation so at
0.5 0.5
so it'll be look like this so one again
to interpret this
is say for this arc up here
so it's connecting an actinobacteria
here
to a bacteries and so this would be
one correlation between them and so
forth you can make
similar associations with the other
edges
and so this is for our uui network and
if we redraw
our controls we get something like this
so some things that are noble is if you
notice
say for firmicutes here we see a very
dense cluster of
uh edges that resonate from around here
and there's a lot more that are going
from the firmicutes here
to proteobacteria that are not as
prevalent or prominent in our controls
over here
and so looking at not only just those
two
i did look at the
pairs of phylum and compare them between
the groups and therebcp
does appear to be a statistical
difference in how
the different phyla may associate in
uui compared to our control group which
is very
interesting to see
now so that's at the final level so
let's look at more of the
generic level and so here i want to look
at
well one question is what may be
important to
the community and so again these network
based methods
allow us to abstract or create
a hypothesis of what the community is
doing and so with this network structure
we can identify
important bacteria in our in our
community
and so one measure of that is what's
called betweenness centrality
and so here's a very simple toy example
of what that may look like so this
blue bacteria
will have a high between a centrality
which loosely speaking is because it's
between
most of the other nodes or bacteria in
our network
and so i've calculated the top
betweenness centrality measures
for each of our eui and control network
and then show them here and so one thing
that we noticed
is that lactobacillus is actually
uh the most betw uh most central
based on or between the centrality in
both these cases
for uh urinary microbiome here
and so one thing you might may be
wondering is what may
be the different connections outside
of that are connected to this bacteria
even though they are both
central to each of these
and so here i want to look at that
overlap so here again i'm
focusing on lactobacillus because it was
found
central to urinary microbiome in both of
these
networks and i'm taking a look at the
surrounding
bacteria in each and then comparing the
overlap of those bacteria
and so what results is this venn diagram
that shows that overlap
and so we can see there are some
differences and some similarities
so there are say 10 of these bacteria
that are common between our uui
and controls they're both associated or
correlated with
lactobacillus then we see 16 that are
unique in our controls
and then 15 or rather 25
bacteria they're newly associated with
lactobacillus and our uui group
so i want to take a moment to take a
look at what these 25 releases
some of them are real quickly
and so some notable so looking into some
of these here
we see that a lot of them are associated
with
some sort of urinary tract infection so
some of them are
more well known like e coli here at the
bottom
or and the other ones here are emerging
neural pathogens
as well so it's very interesting to see
uh
like like the bacillus can be a very
strong player
but also be associated with these more
um euro pathogen players as well
so just brief summary of the union
microbiome network findings here
and so based on just stripping network
measures here that the uui network here
is less clustered
they lessen these structured groups and
their controls
the ui network has more
observed microbial co-occurrences or
more of these edges
between the bacteria
we found that lactobacillus is central
to both of these
and that when we look at the eui group
there is specific and associated with
lactobacillus we say that a lot of them
are associated
with some sort of infection
now switching gears slightly we're going
to go into the vaginal microbiome now
so here is a visual representation of
that
just as a quick visual so again same
clustering algorithm
to just identify just general structure
here
so we have five groups in our ui group
and then
six groups and our controls so just
briefly looking at
some of the statistics here uh the
number of bacteria in each of these is
actually very similar
however the number of edges or the
number of associations
co-occurrences we see for our eui group
is a lot more than our controls
being 396 to 195.
and then based on the structure of these
networks the modularity
of how the clustering algorithm works
uh the modulator appears to be the same
and then normalized connectants here
because it's again as a reminder it's
related to
the number of edges that we see versus
all possible ones
and because there's a lot more edges
here we can see that there's an
increased normalized
connectant here
okay now very similar to before i want
to
focus on the phylum level information
but again here is very difficult to see
so i've remapped everything around
to look like a hive plot and so
here again is what that would look like
for the vaginal microbiome using the
the networks correspondingly
then so here we can also see some slight
differences
and how there are a lot more
associations between say bacteria these
and fermicutes and our
ui versus in our controls where we don't
see as
dense of associations or other stronger
associations between them
and so forth and then similarly i also
compared
all these different pairwise
correlations of the or
not pairwise correlations taking all the
pairwise
um like number of associations between
these different phylum and compare those
and there does seem to be a difference
in how the phylum associate in our uui
compared to our controls
and then going in a little bit into the
bacteria themselves or the individual
nodes again i'm looking at
the centrality measure or what's most
central
bacteria in these networks for the
vaginal microbiome
and so for controls we see that
lactobacillus
is quite central to this network which
is unsurprising considering its
dominance
in an importance in the vaginal
microbiome however for
uui cases we see that we have this other
one
called aerococcus as being the most
central or important
one to this network and it's in between
this is much higher than
the rest of them so i would like to
dig into it just slightly here
and so actually there's been some recent
research on
this bacteria and
one species of aerococcus here is
actually associated with
utis urinary tract infections
in the urinary microbiome actually
published earlier this year
and so how is this related to talk about
the vaginal microbiome because again
this aerococcus was found
in the vaginal microbiome here or rather
most central
so i mentioned that we're interested in
that the vaginal microbiome because of
its close proximity
and serves as a potential reservoir for
uh infecting bacteria uh such as
aerococcus and some
aerococcus or other urinary tract
infections here
and then furthermore to push or to to
add to the story of
the potential infections
here i'm looking at looking at focusing
at the aerocaucus
in our ui network and looking at the
neighbors or whatever else
it co-occurs with and here
at the top two here that i have based on
average relative abundance
we have guard norella and prevotella
and looking at the literature here these
two are actually quite
prevalent in being associated with
bacteria um a irrigant infection called
bacteria
vaginosis again another type of
infection
that may find its way through the
urinary tract
to then cause possible issues with
uui
this is some summaries on the vaginal
microbiome
here so again based on our
large network measures the dui group is
less clustered based on the
these large topological measures
and there are also more observed
co-occurrences
of these bacteria in our ui group
and we also found this aerococcus genus
as being
central to the eui group that wasn't
found in our
controls and furthermore when we looked
at aerococcus
it is um can be found
in what sorry
the bacteria that are correlated with
aerocarcus when we look at the
bacteria in our eui group those bacteria
are
commonly found with vaginal infections
and then so to wrap up all of the
bounces we've seen so way back
we talked about more of these
traditional analyses and we didn't find
any
microbial differences in both the urine
and
vagina between our group's ui and their
controls
and so this may suggest that micro
the microbiome analyses or the
traditional ones rather
don't account for these ecological
interactions may be
important to understand these more
nuanced differences and so
we have shown that network methods may
help in exploring
this abstract and invisible microbial
community structure that we don't have
immediate access to
and then using that we can then identify
central bacteria in these structures and
find that
some of them may be associated with
their general infections and then
going forward this may play a role in
devising more hypotheses and how it
might treat
ui going forward
so with that i would like to thank
everybody who's helped me along the way
very importantly my committee lisa at
least
tim and mark who isn't
um unfortunately passed away last year
um but yeah thank you to everybody uh
it taught me a lot along the way
i hope to take uh all your teachings
with me
going forward uh the division of your
gynecology for
all your clinical expertise to help me
understand uui from many different
perspectives
thank you for your time and and
attention as well uh the carson's lab
for uh having being a home for me to
grow and to share my work and also to
listen to everybody else
else's very cool work uh there wasn't
bob ask with lab for helping me with
the sample processing and also being
a great group to hang out with the
demise staff and fellows
for all their support and guidance along
these years
uh helping me get through this friends
and family
and then of course my funding sources
the
sufu organization the nlm and then
iddk so with that i
will take questions thank you
great thank you eric any um
[Music]
any questions um
i'm sorry go ahead someone
might be i can either unmute or um
or type into the chat box
i guess maybe one well one one thing
that's interesting and there's there's a
number of clinicians
um and and i've chatted with lisa about
this in the past
um you know the teaching in in
medicine at least when i was in medical
school a while ago
you know is that um the
the urine is sterile um and
um you know only when there are
infections can we
um grow out bacteria but clearly um
the microbiome um is there perhaps not
detectable
by the normal clinical methods
you know that physicians have for
diagnosing things like urinary tract
infection
it's just um you know and then maybe i
guess an uh a
question um so i mean clearly there are
differences here
um you know are and and perhaps this is
beyond the scope of
of your work but you know are are these
differences you know what's the cause
and effect here
is that is the microbiome
causing these conditions or is um
or are these conditions somehow causing
the changes in the microbiome which i
recognize may not
be answerable from the work you've done
sure yeah i yeah as usually just yeah i
don't i don't know if it can be
uh answerable it's a fascinating
question i think it leads to a lot of
different
um possible you know grants that could
be written right
um but yeah i mean one one thing i bring
up here is like the context of
the vaginal microbiome and so i think
that has a
really nice um avenue to explore
um one one idea is to kind of
leverage this more ecological thought i
somebody gave
um i think i was like confidence
somebody
gave me an idea um to
to try to simulate how um
the vaginal microbiome hypothesis if
your hypothesis
is that like the vaginal microbiome like
completely seeds
the urinary microbiome um in
in its former sterile state and
may succeed it more um you can do like
some sampling
to see if you can reproduce or like how
yeah sample from the vaginal microbiome
into like a
simulated urinary microbiome and maybe
compare them
and that could be a way to understand
the
at least the creation
of the urinary microbiome but then i
think your question
also talked about the uh more disease
state and like which one is like a cause
and effect is that right
um yeah that that's a hard
hard problem and i think with the
microbiome like even
even working on this it's it's very hard
not to think about
all the different confounding factors
that you have to consider when
doing um like very causal
microbiome research considering like
microbiome or like bacteria or
they exist and
developed between individuals like
between other bacteria but also shaped
by their environment
so yeah i
know that was a long-winded answer to
say yeah i i'm not sure either
so yeah no that's that's fine um and
there's some
um i don't know if you can see it
because it's hard to see the chat box
when you're
screen sharing but there's um a question
from rose and another
question from mina so yeah
okay yeah i can see that so yeah bros
do you apply your machine learning
analysis directly
to any other microbiomes or would you
have to tweak your processes
per microbiome oh yeah that's
interesting but um
i mean the the methods are so
the network part of it could be applied
to others but i feel like
because the microbiome is very
heterogeneous
uh it it there's a lot of nuances that
i've i've come up with
along the way that make it more
difficult to analyze
um like for example at the very
beginning i showed that there's a lot of
um these i guess i could show it
at the very beginning i did the like
clustering analysis
and showed that there's quite a bit of
structure
in these like two groups where is it
yeah so like here there's like some
major groupings
in our microbiome and this isn't uh
surprising other studies
also will try to group and identify
um like these uh
certain sample or participants with very
dominant bacteria
especially yeah especially in the urine
and vagina
and so
it's long another long-winded answer to
uh yes you would have to tweak it
uh to to apply to other microbiomes
i think that's what make makes
microbiome research
very difficult uh because of this like
variability um so
oh yes and then mina thanks mina let's
see negative correlation will be
interesting to explore
differences in the unique bacterial
colonies between dui
and the earth controls in beyond maybe
due to some negative effects
so i guess more of a comment on negative
correlations yeah so i mean
yeah negative correlations i've my
committee also asked me this question
and it's
it's an interesting area the more i you
know it seems very
intuitive and the more i looked into the
literature people were very
uncertain on how to make use of it
and because a negative correlation
so a positive correlation sometimes i've
used the term
co-occurrence or things that co occur or
you see
them present together um
but doing the opposite where like one
bacteria goes up and another bacteria
goes down it's very difficult
to ensure or say
um so one analogy uh somebody
helped me develop or like you know just
talking it out is kind of like um
being at a bar um
that like if if i keep on going to the
same bar but like you aren't at the bar
does that mean we necessarily don't like
each other or have some
beef uh not necessarily
um and then also there is actually some
specific work i saw some publications
that came out earlier this year that
actually
designed specifically to look at
negative correlations
because when you look at
a bacteria as a this example of having
like all of one bacteria and then seeing
none of another
the the shape of your data
and how it looks is very difficult to
infer so
um that'll be interesting
yeah so long story short uh my answer to
that would be
or comment is that looking at negative
correlations in the microbiome and also
how to incorporate with the positive
correlations there's a
an open area to to explore because um
yeah it's it's difficult to to
assess what what that might mean and how
to
accurately quantify it
thank you all right jennifer i see your
question
let's see what you see
as next steps for this research what
needs to be done before treatments can
be developed for
uui okay so first off i'm not a
clinician
second the this is a great question
i think oh
let's see you've seen next steps
so it's difficult for me to answer
because
there's i've added the um
so the vaginal microbiome is new so that
adds a whole other piece
of information there
let's see why it's going to be developed
yeah so hypothetically you know maybe
the end product would
be some sort of probiotic
or bacterial supplement or
cream that could be applied
with more evidence and support on
having this the vaginal as being a place
for influencing the health of the your
genital tract and
your urinary tract in general
um i know there is uh evidence to show
that um if i recall correctly using like
uh topical estrogen cream uh can reduce
the number of recurrent utis
so one thing could be
possible is uh developing you know
an end product may be some sort of
probiotic cream that can be applied to
change the microbiota the vaginal
microbiome
to then maybe help the health of the
planet microbiome
and so to get there you would then have
to identify
how changes in the vaginal microbiome
could
create or be associated with a healthy
fat urinary microbiome so i'm kind of
thinking backwards from like
the treatment back to how you do it so i
guess what would be next
is how to
yeah just just get more samples uh
uh or funding for looking at
specifically like more
vaginal and urinary microbiome samples
that are collected together
so you can see how both of them vary
because i don't
think it is very feasible to
directly influence the urinary
microbiome through
say an injection or something so
okay see great
yeah i know we're at times let me see
what other uh
thank you uh thank you eric for a great
great talk
and um what we'll do now is we will
um dismiss the the general audience
including myself and leave you to your
committee who may have further questions